[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العلوي
الجمهوريون في طريقهم نحو الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب
والمنافسه محتدمه حول السيطره على مجلس
الشيوخ
اعدام شخصين
رئيس مجلس نظارات البجه يقول ان البيان
الانفصالي للجنه السياسيه لا يمثل شرق
السودان
ومكرو ينهي عمليه برخان رسميا في منطقه
الساحل كبدايه لعمليه التكيف كبيره
للقواعد الفرنسيه في افريقيا
اهلا بكم الساعه المقبله ستكون حاسمه
لتحرير مصير السياسه الامريكيه ومن سيطر
على مجالس القرار في واشنطن في احداث
المعلومات حصل الجمهوريون على 2007 مقاعد
في مجلس النواب مقابله
288 للديمقراطيين بحسب شبكه اي بي سي في
حين منحت الجمهوريين محطه سي ان ان
1099 مقعدا مقابله
278 الديمقراطيين هذا فيما تتساوى النتائج
في مجلس الشيوخ بحصول الديمقراطيين على 48
مقعدا مقابله مثلهم للجمهوريين
وفي وقتنا اعزائي المشاهدين لا تبينوا
الارقام حتى الان سيطره كامله لاي من
الحزبين على مجلس الشيوخ ينتظر الجميع
نتائج الولايات المتبقيه حتى الان وهي
جورجيا اريزونا وسكنسن ونيفادا
وتشير التوقعات الى ان الجمهوريين سيفوزون
بمقعد وستينسون في حين يتوقع ان تكون
اريزونا من نصيب الديمقراطيه
لينحصر الصراع الذي سيحسم مجلس الشيوخ في
ولايتين هما جورجيا في الجنوب الشرقي
ونفادا في الغرب الامريكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سبايدر سبايدر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الناس
[موسيقى]
هنا هنا
وبيراميد
ز
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في البيت الابيض
اما هناك فقد خسر حزب الرئيس قد تنقلب
الطاوله ويصدق استطلاع مؤسسه اديسون
للابحاث لاراء الناخبين لدى خروجهم من
مراكز الاقتراع في الانتخابات النصفيه
بالولايات المتحده حيث اظهر الاستطلاع ان
نحو سبعه من كل 10 من المقترعين لا يؤيدون
ترشح الرئيس جوبيد لولايه لرئاسيه ثانيه
لكن في الوقت نفسه اعرب نحو سته من كل
عشره عن راي سلبي بشان الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
بين ريال الديمقراطيين وتطلع الجمهوريين
تبقى الموجه الحمراء قيد الانتظار لتحدد
ملامح اداء رئيس البلاد خلال الفتره
المقبله في انتظار ما تبقى من النتائج
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
من مدينه هاريس بورد بولايه بنسلفانيا
ينضم اليه مراسل العربيه في الغانم ومن
واشنطن مراسله العربيه
جدا حتى الساعه مراسل العربيه حسين الطور
ابقى معك فير من بنسلفانيا جديد المشهد
الانتخابي في هذه الاوقات اخر الارقام
واخر النتائج حتى الساعه التي وصلت بها
بس الفنيه شهيده حدث مهمه جدا خلال ساعات
الليل اولا انتصر المرشح الديمقراطي
منصب مجلس الشيوخ جون فترمين على منافسه
الجمهوري ولكن الاهم ان هذا الديمقراطي
اخذ مقعدا كان اصلا للجمهوريين وكان
المرشح او عضو مجلس الشيوخ من بنسلفانيا
تومي جمهوريه لكنه قرر عدم الترشح
وبالتالي خسر الجمهوريون مقعدا في هذه
الولايه من مجلس الشيوخ بالنسبه لمنصب
حاكم الولايه انتصر ايضا المرشح
الديمقراطي شافيرو بفارق جيد عن منافسهم
وعمليه ولكن لا يجب ان نضع هذا النموذج
على مستوى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الشخصيات الجمهوريان اللذان كان مدعومين
من قبل الرئيس ترامب قد خسر طواقيعه
طيب يعني انتقل يبقى انتقل الى ناديه
ناديه همم ايضا اخر الارقام التي وصلت في
اخر النتائج وما هو محسوم حتى الساعه وما
هو غير المحسوم
اا اريد ان ابدا لو سمحت لي ربما بالجو
العام في البيت الابيض يعني هناك تنفس
للصعداء الجميع كان يتوقع موجه حمراء
ترتاح الولايات المتحده في ظل الارقام
الاقتصاديه سواء كان من تضخم او كساد
مرتقب لكن الناخب الامريكي وضع قضايا اخرى
مثل الاجهاض والديمقراطيه التي حملها
الرئيس بايرن شعارا لذا اعتقد بان هناك
شعور بالفعل بان همم الناخب الامريكي اتى
الى جانب البيت الابيض في ظروف صعبه جدا
وحتى الان كما تعرف همم الارقام غير ثابته
لكن في مجلس النواب يتوقع كما قلنا طوال
اليوم في السابق بان الجمهوريه سيطرون
عليه لانهم فقط بحاجه الى خمس همم مقاعد
لكن الموجه الحمراء التي توقعها البعض ان
لن تتحقق وبالتالي رغم اعلان كيف المقال
في وهو سيكون رئيس الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب النصر مسبقا الا انه طبعا سيكون
لديه اغلبيه بسيطه جدا في مجلس النواب حتى
الان اعتقد 221 مقعدا لصالح الجمهوريين
لكن كما ذكرت طالب الاعين هي على مجلس
الشيوخ يعني في افضل الاحوال همم يمكن
للديمقراطيين همم عفوا للجمهوريين ان
يحتفظوا همم كما يعني كما هو الواضح حاليا
بان يكون هناك 50 50 وبالتالي ينقسم
المجلس مره اخرى كما هو لكن الفرق سيحضر
بالنسبه لنائبه الرئيس كماله التي ستصوت
الى صالح همم
هذا الخبر العاجل يعني الصوت هذا اللي ما
تقولين البيت الابيض يقول ان النتائج حتى
الساعه هي استنتاجات وغير نهائيه ان
النتائج الانتخابات النصفيه حتى الساعه هي
استنتاجات وهي غير نهائيا ينتقل الى حسين
الطوب من جورجيا واا يعني ام المعارك كانت
في جورجيا وحتى الساعه لم تحسم همم يحصل
موضوع همم
الترشح لمجلس الشيوخ في جورجيا همم اخر
المعلومات متوفر لديك اخر الارقام التي
وصلتك حسين وكيف هي الاجواء من جورجيا
بالفعل طالبه جورجيا هي الساحه الانتخابيه
الحاسمه كما وصفت الارقام متقاربه بين
المرشحين الرئيسيين ووكر على الحزب
الجمهوري ورافاييل الغرناق السنه طلعت
الديمقراطي الحالي طبعا كان متوقعا ان
تكون همم الارقام متقاربه بسبب ايضا وجود
مرشح ثالث اخذ من دربيما وهو اول شيس
اوليفر عن الحزب النيبرالي همم حتى الان
لم يستطع احد ان يحسمها هناك طوال الليل
كان هناك تراه همم بالنتائج ما
بيننا لهذا السبب هناك توقعات من ان نذهب
الى دوله اعاده الى لم يحصل اي من
المرشحين على 50% من الاصوات كما ينص
ااا قانون هنا في جورجيا همم جوله الاعاده
ستكون في السادس من ديسمبر في اعاده
لسيناريو عام 2020 الذي فاز خلاله غرناك
بجوله الاعاده همم تاريخيا طالب اشاره الى
ذكر ان
الجمهوريون فازوا منذ عام 1960 وحتى عام
2020 كان هناك احد عشر دوله اعاده
الجمهوريون فاز بسبعه منها ولكن
الديمقراطيون الان يقولون اذا حدثت جوله
الاعاده فهي لصالح وارناك لسبب ان الحاكم
برايم كم لن يكون على ورقه الاقتراعه وهو
ساعدنا همم او عفوا السعاده هيرش الوكر
بصعود همم بالحصول على اصوات كثيره في
جوله الاعاده لن يكون موجوده لذلك ستكون
لصالحوار هناك كذه يتوقعون كما قلنا حتى
الان تم فرز نحو همم 96% الاصوات هناك
اربعه بالمئه همم يفرزونها ولكن الفارق
بين المرشحين هرش الوكر وراء ريال ورناك
هو تقريبا
0,5% 18,000 صوتا فقط الفرق بينهما لهذا
همم قد تتاخر النتيجه ايه لوقت متاخر من
اليوم او حتى للغد واذا نذكر اذا لم يحصل
اي منهما على 50% نحن ذاهبون الى جوله
اعاده في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل طيب
حسين نبقى معي سعودي الى بير همم يعني
تابعت في التغطيه انت وجميع الزملاء
يعطيكم العافيه كل هذه الانتخابات اين
كانت كبرى المفاجاه تعبير ام لا ما كان
متوقعا قد تم
حسب التقديرات بعض
المستطيل كانوا يتحدثون عن ان هناك ستكون
موجه حمراء وانها الجمهوريين سوف
يتمكنونها من سحق الديمقراطيين والسيطره
بسهوله على المجلسين البعض الاخر اعتبرها
ان هذه المعركه هي معركه متقاربه جدا ونحن
الاشهد هذا الاكتساح
عمليا الذين انتظروا ان تكون معركه
متقاربه جدا لن يفاجئوا بهذه النتائج همم
هناك بعض المؤشرات الايجابيه جدا بالنسبه
الديمقراطيين حافظوا على بعض مقاعد مجلس
النواب الامريكي مثل في فرجينيا همم
وكانوا يتوقعون خساره مقعد او مقعدين
لكنهم حافظوا على هذه المقاعد هناك مفاجات
اخرى موجوده في ولايه نيويورك حيث تراجعت
شعبيه الديمقراطيين الى حد كبير جدا لكنه
جمهوري لم يستطيعوا من كسب المعركه الرئيس
ترامب كان ينتظر ان تكون هناك انتصارات
كبيره جدا تسمح له ان يكون
القائد المكرر بالنسبه للجمهوريين ربما
يكون تفاجا ايضا بان هذا الاكتساح وهذه
الارقام والشخصيات التي تؤيده لم تحقق
النجاحات التي كان يتبناها طيب نادي يعود
اليك حتى الساعه هل يمكن الحديث عن نصف
انتصار للجمهوريين في مقابل نصف هزيمه
للديمقراطيين ام لا حتى هذا التوصيف غير
دقيق
يعني يمكن بس كما قال بيار كان هناك
بالفعل توقع بان يكون هناك نصر اكبر
للجمهوريين وبالتالي اريحيه في الحكم في
مجلس النواب ربما هذا لن يتحقق ايضا
الرئيس ترامب الان بالنسبه للمرشحين الذين
دعمهم هناك حديث بدا اليوم بالتحديد بعد
فوز الخصم المتوقع للرئيس ترامب في
الانتخابات الاوليه اذا ترشحترام طبعا وهو
راند سانتوس حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الذي همم
حصل على فوز كبير جدا يعني اا هناك كانت
فجوه بينه وبين المنافس بالنسبه له
وبالتالي بدا الحديث الان على ان
الجمهوريين عليهم ان يقوموا بمراجعه
داخليه
ربما
راى الرئيس ترامب بطريقه عمياء يعني معظم
مرشحين قد لم يفوزوا هناك مرشح طبعا
ذكرتي يعني روندي سانتوس لماذا هذا الهجوم
همم
يعني الشرس من الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
على ديسانتوس يعني حتى الاوصاف التي
اطلقها عليها اليوم يعني حذره من الترشح
وانه يعرف عنه اشياء واشياء حتى زوجته لا
تعرف ذلك ما سر هذا الهجوم
السير بسيط جدا وهو انه يراه الخصم المؤهل
لان يقود الحزب الجمهوري يعني عوده مره
اخرى الى الحزب التقليدي الذي عرفناه في
السابق قبل ظهور ترامب على الساحه همم
واختطافي اذا اردت الى اجنده الحزب
الجمهوري الذي يرى البعض بينها اصبحت
شعبويه بان ترامب يعين اشخاص فقط يدينون
بالولاء له ليسوا مؤهلين وكما راينا هزيمه
ل همم وهو الطبيب الذي دعامه ترامب الذي
اتى من يرجزي وخمسكن في كنسلفانيا لفتره
قصيره فقط ليترشح هذا المقعد وخسر
وبالتالي هناك ايضا خسرات اخرى في مجلس
النواب بالنسبه للرئيس ترامب لكن ترامب
يرى نفسه بانه هو عراب الحزب الجمهوري
وبالتالي لن يسمح لاي شخص اخر هو سيدمر كل
منافس له ليس فقط لسانتوس لكن ايضا
واي شخص اخر لكن هو الاكثر ليه التاهل
وبالتالي هي الشعب الفعل ان يكون هناك
انجراف الان بعد خساره او عدم فوز
الجمهوريين اذا اردت
بالاغلبيه كما كان متوقع ان يكون هناك
انجراف نحو هذا المرشح الشاب والذي يحكم
ولايه مهمه مثل ولايه فلوريدا والذي يعد
من الجمهوريين التقليديه
مع حسين حسين همم هل سجلت اي احداث لنقل
العنف احداث
معينه لفتك خلال المعركه في جورجيا ام لا
الامور كانت يعني بثلاثه لم يعكر صفها اي
شيء
كانت التصويت كان ثالث حسب ما قال العديد
من الناخبين ولكن طبعا سجل عدد من الشكاوى
بالنسبه للطيور في قوائم الناخبين عدد من
الناخبين عندما اتى ليصوت في مكتبه
الاقتراع وجد ان اسمه غير موجود في هذا
المكتب عليه ان يذهب الى مكتب اخر كان
يقول لنا اننا نحن هنا نعيش في هذه
المنطقه منذ 10 سنوات ولكن بسبب القانون
الجديد همم خلونا انتخابيط وضع حواجز وهذا
ما كان حضر منه معارضوه القانون خاصه من
الديمقراطيين الذين قالوا ان هذا القانون
سيضع حواجز الامامه عدد من همم من
الناخبين لاسيما من الامريكيين من اصول
افريقيه رغم ان حاكم الولايه كان قال ان
هذا القانون سيسهل التصويت ولكنه يمنع
الغش طبعا كان هناك ايضا شكاوى من همم من
حيث
بدايه السلطات هنا فتحت فما احدى
المقاطعات بشان همم الاقتراع البريدي
الغيابي همم الذي قالت ان احدى المقاطعات
لم ترسل اكثر من 1000 همم
ورقه اقتراع الى الناخبين وقال همم
ابراهيم كاب ان ذلك غير مقبول هذا مشاهدنا
ايضا كان هناك امبارح كان شيء لطيف في
الحقيقه نحن نعرف ان هنا في جورجيا
القانون الجديد يمنع توزيع الماء واعطاء
الماء للناخبين لذلك قامت الجمعيات التي
تاتي تقوم بذلك وابتعدت همم نحو مسافه 50
متر ولكنهم وضعوا موسيقى مرتفعه وصاحبه
ليجذب من يريد ان يحصل على المراه والطعام
اليهما لكن هم لم يقترب منهم وضعه همم
لائحه تقول الطعام مجانا
ياكل فليتفضل ولم يختار لكنهم لم يختاروا
المراكز الاقتراع فسر لنا ايضا واوضح لنا
همم
سنكون معك فور يعني لا غبار المعركه في
جورج احسان الطوب من جورجيا شكرا شكرا
ايضا من واشنطن لمراسله العربي ناديه
البلبيسي ومن هاريسبور بي ولايه
بالسلفينيا بنسلوفينيا في ارغانم شكرا
جزيلا لكبير على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ازاي المشاهدين تحت الانتخابات النصفيه
للكونغرس الامريكيه في مرحله هامه وخاصه
تمر بها الولايات المتحده ما يجعل هذه
الجوله مؤثره بشكل كبير ليس فقط على مقاعد
الكونجرس بل على الحياه السياسيه للبلاد
في قادم السنوات
كانت مجرد انتخابات لتجديد نصف مقاعد
الكونجرس الامريكي بل هي لحظه في الحياه
السياسيه للولايات المتحده
فلنتائجها واقع كبير على المستقبل القريب
لامريكا
ريح تغيير ان هبت فانها ستطال اولا سياسات
جو بايدن خلال السنتين المتبقيتين له في
ولاياته فاجندته قد تواجه بعض العراقيل
كما ان المسار الديمقراطي على المحاك سيا
ما في ظل تعالي خطاب التشكيك في نزاهه
الانتخابات من طرف مناصرها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وهو ما يعني
ان الانتخابات الحاليه هي امتحان
للديمقراطيه فاما اعاده الاعتبار للمشهد
الديمقراطي في البلاد او تكريس الشكوك
التي تتزايد شيئا فشيئا من شان الانتخابات
الحاليه ان تلقي بظلالها ايضا على
العمليات الانتخابيه المقبله على المدى
المتوسط والقريب حيث قد يعمل فريق
الجمهوريين بشكل خاص على بلوره افكار
لاعاده تشكيل الدوائر الانتخابيه وتغيير
الاجراءات الانتخابيه على مستوى الولايات
عامل المهيمن اخرج على الانتخابات النصفيه
ذات اهميه خاصه فهي تعد مؤشرا حقيقيا لرسم
خريطه حظوظ المرشحين للرئاسيات القادمه
سواء تعلق الامر بالرئيس الحالي بعدنا او
السابق ترامب او غيرهما فهي وحده لقياس
مدى شعبيه كل حزب وقدرته على جذب اصوات
النبي العربيه
قراءه ولو اوليه في
الاوليه ايضا همم لهذه الانتخابات ام لا
النصفيه والتي لم
تبحامل نتائجها حتى الساعه وهل حسابات
الحقل همم عند الجمهوريين كانت غير حسابات
البيدر كما شاهدنا يعني كانوا يتوقعون
اكتساح موجه حمراء ولكن لا حسابات الحقل
كانت غير حسابات البيده
انا بحضرتك واهلا المشاهدين انتخابات
مثيره جدا والنتائج الاوليه مثيره وقابله
للتغير في اي لحظه ويبدو اا يعني كما اا
قالت الاستاذه ناديه بالبيسي مراسلتكم ان
همم لا يوجد ما يسمى بالموجه الحمراء في
هذه الانتخابات كما كان يتوقع الجمهوريون
لكن تبدو الامور تسير في اتجاه سيطرتهم
الى على مجلس النواب بشكل او باخر حتى
اللحظه مجلس الشيوخ تبدو فيه الامور يعني
همم فيفتي 50 50
همم ربما نشاهد تغير في اي لحظه من
اللحظات ربما يفوز الجمهوريون بالمقعد
الزائد المطلوب لتحقيق همم فارق همم الصوت
الوحيد وربما وتبقى المجلس الشيوخ كما هو
وضعه الان همم بنسبه 50 50 وصوت همم نائبه
الرئيس هو المرجح في همم التصويت
في تشريعات وبالتالي همم اذا ما بقي مجلس
الشيوخ كما هو وسيطر الجمهوريون على مجلس
النواب اعتقد سيكون هذا مسمار جحا
للجمهوريين في الكونجرس وتحت قبته للوقوف
امام العديد من القرارات الرئاسيه للرئيس
جو بايدن او المخططات التشريعيه التي يسعى
الحزب الديمقراطي لتمريرها من خلال مجلس
النواب ومن ثم الى الشيوخ الى اخره ف- اا
الجمهوريون اذا ما حققوا هذه السيطره انا
اعتقد هذا سيكون انجاز كبير بالنسبه لهم
لانهم خسروا كل شيء في الانتخابات الماضيه
البيت الابيض والكونجرس بمجلسي وطبعا
الشكل همم
غير المعتاد همم للمواطن الامريكي الذي
خرج من الاعتراض بشكل اا يعني كان مفرد في
استخدام القوه والشكل الاعترادي غير
المرحب به داخل الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
فعندما يقومون بالف بمجلس النواب بعدها
بعامين فقد هذا سيكون انجاز يستطيعون ان
يبوا عليه طيب سذهب بالنسبه الى الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب هل تعتقد ان هذه
النتائج
نعود ونؤكد انها اوليه ستعطيه اريحيه وقوه
للذهاب في الخامس عشر يعني الثلاثاء
القادم ليعلن ترشيحه من موقع القوه ام لا
سيكون بموقع ضعف خصوصا ما ذكره زميلي فير
بان مرشحي الرئيس ترامب او الذين دعمهم
الرئيس ترامب خسروا هذه المعركه
يعني انا اتفق بشكل او باخر مع هذه الرؤيه
ولكن هي ليست كل الرؤيه الكبيره او ليست
كل الصوره الكبيره بمعنى ان الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب فاول على هؤلاء الاشخاص
المرشحين من الحزب الجمهوري كا محاوله منه
لزياده الزخم المطلوب لتحقيق احتماليه
عودته للانتخابات الرئاسيه لكن من يعتمد
عليهم اصلا الرئيس دونالد ترامب هم جمهور
الجمهوريين همم الجمهوري رجل الشارع
الجمهوري الاشخاص الذين يتاثرون بخطابه
الشعبوي وكريسماته اتفقنا او اختلفنا معها
الموجوده لديه والتي تحقق الكثير من
الاحساس بالتشبع السياسي البسيط لدى
المواطن الامريكي العادي الذي يتاثر
بكلماته ويخرج من اجل مناصته فهو ربما اا
يعني حاول الاستعانه بالنخب السياسيه في
الحزب الجمهوري المترشحين في الولايات
المختلفه كحكام وك واقف في المجلسين الا
ان قاعده العريضه تاتي من ما يقرب من ال
150 ما يقرب من ال 150 بول- اا عفوا من من
ال- اا من ال 73 مليون او 72 مليون مواطن
امريكي الذين انتخبوه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه ويبدو انه يحافظ على
زخمهم وكمياتهم الكبيره وهذا سيتضح اذا ما
اعلن ترشحه للانتخابات ام لا بالاضافه الى
طبعا المشاكل القضائيه التي يواجهها في
ولايه نيويورك وبعض الولايات الاخرى ستلعب
دور كبير وانت تتحدث فقط اسف للمقاطعه
مسؤول انتخابات في ولايه جورجيا يقول ان
الولايه تتجه الى الدعوه لاعاده همم
الانتخابات على مقعد الشيوخ وان هذه
الجوله ستعقد في السادس من السمبر اولا هل
من تعليق بمعنى انه لم يفوز يعني او
الارقام حتى الساعه لم تفرز فائزا
وبالتالي ستكون هنالك جوله اعاده في
السادس من السمبر ما الذي يعني ذلك
يعني هذا يعني ان الامور ستظل متارجح حتى
السادس من ديسمبر يعني سنظل تقريبا شهر
بعد اجراء هذه الجوله الانتخابيه في
انتظار هذا الصوت وربما يكون او هذا
المقعد ربما هذا المقعد يكون هو المقعد
المرجح في نهايه المطاف يعني ننتظر شهرا
حتى نعرف تماما من يسيطر ربما على مجلس
النواب خاصه ان ولايه نيفادا في المقابل
ايضا الامور تبدو فيها ما زالت متارجحه
وربما تاتي بجديد همم طبقا لتوقعات همم
مختلفه يعني من الممكن ان يكون الجمهوريون
يتوقعوا ان نيفاذ نيفادا ستذهب لهم ولكن
يفاجئوا بانها تذهب الى الديمقراطين
والعكس صحيح وفي جورجيا نفس الشيء يعني
نسب والفروقات التي تعدوا باقل من واحد
بالمئه هذه ستلعب الدوري الحاسم في تحديد
مجلس الشيوخ الخبير في الشارع الامريكي
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه السياسيه
نشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
الصليب الاحمر الدولي يحذر من تفاقم
المعاناه في سوريا ولبنان بسبب زياده عدد
اصابات بالكوليرا
اهلا بكم جديد نفذت السلطات الايرانيه حكم
الاعدام بحق شخصين بعد اذنتهما بتهم
القيام باعمال الارهابيه وزعزعه الامن
واطلاق النار نحو قوى الامن الداخلي وقتل
اربعه من كوادر حرس الحدود في محافظه
الزهدان بستان بلوشستان جنوب شرقي البلاد
وفقا ما اعلنت وكاله وفارس للانباء
الايراني وكانت وزيره الخارجيه كندا ميلان
جولي قد نددت بدعوه النظام لادام متظاهرين
معتقلين وطالب الطهران بمراجعه هذا القرار
ياتي هذا في وقت قالت فيه منظمه هنداو
الكرديه لحقوق الانسان ان اضرابا واسعاره
يجتاح حمودنا محافظه كردستان غرب ايران في
ذكرى الاربعين لمقتل المتظاهرين بمدينه
ذهب واضافت ان الاضراب شمل مدنها كارمن
شاه وسندج وماريفان
معمل لندن لمزيد من من المتابعه الان حول
هذا الموضوع الكاتب المتخصص في الشان
الايرانيه الدكتور نبيل الحيدري دكتور
نبيل اهلا وسهلا بك نشات الخامسه اي توصيف
يمكن اعطاءه الاحتجاجات اليوم في
المحافظات الايرانيه وهل ما زالت هذه
الاحتجاجات
والتظاهرات وفوق متابعتك بنفس الزخم ام لا
كل ما تقدم الوقت كلما خفت وبردت الى حد
ما
تحيه لك يا دكتور طالب ومشاهدي قناه
العربيه طبعا همم لا زالت حقيقه في نحن
اليوم الرابع والخمسين يعني في نهايه
الشهر الثاني ولم يحصل في كل تاريخ ايران
التي غايه الاحتجاجات وصلت 10 ايام يعني
اكثر من خمسه اضعاف لا زالت في زخمها
والدليل اليوم هو طبعا همم يشهد
اربعينيتان اربعينيه في بالنسبه للبلوش
وهو مجزره الجمعه السوداء ذهب اكثر من 100
شهيد في سلندج وكان يوم الجمعه ويصلون
وهذا ما تحدث عنها همم الشيخ عبد الحميد
حقيقه لذلك اليوم راينا هنالك عزل لي
الرئيس همم الجهاز الامني في همم
بالشوستان همم
وايضا سابقا قد عزل قائد الشرطه وهمم
مسؤول المخفر 16
ولكن طبعا المفروض كما قال عبد الحميد
محاكمه هؤلاء ليس مجود عزلهم ومحاسبه
المسؤولين هو حمل الموشد نفسه خامنئي لانه
ماذا لانه هو القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
وايضا عندنا في كردستان هنالك اربعينيه
احمدي اذا كردستان
التي هي حقيقه من القوميات المهمهشه ومن
السنه
لا يبدو ان السلطات الايرانيه قلقه من كل
ما يجري يعني اليوم يعني حتى اليوم نفذت
السلطات الايرانيه حكم الاعدام بشخصين
بتهم تتعلق باعمال ارهابيه وقتل الاربعه
من القوات الامن
بالعكس القلق واضح جدا على اعلى السلطات
حقيقه
وحتى هذا لهذه العمليه التي حصلت في 2019
بحجه انهم ينتسبون الى جيش العدل وقتلوا
اربع عسكريين لماذا الان يعدمونهم لانه
الان زخم المظاهرات في الاربعينيه كما
راينا في الاربعينيات مساء اماني الان
الاربعينيه
واصفهان ومشهد كانت معها لماذا لانها في
ذكرى اربعينيه زاهيدان هم هنالك تلاحم
بعنوان همم شهداء زاهدان التي هي اكبر
مجزوه في كل هذه الاحتيازات تصور في يوم
واحد اكثر من 100 شهيد فلذلك لا زالت في
زخمها واليوم ساعه خامسه تنطلق في كل
المدن الايرانيه حقيقه مظاهرات واسعه واين
امس كانت كيف قويه واستطاعه هؤلاء الشباب
بقوتهم لذلك الاعدامات عملوها الان لانهم
سابقا كانوا يتوقعون ان هذه الاعدامات سوف
توهبهم لكن هذا الجيل الجديد كما وعيناه
لم توهبوا هذا قالوا اذا قتلتم منا 10 خرج
الف وفعلا هؤلاء الان تعلم سيدي كم عدد
الذين اختطفوا لا نعلم احياء او اموات
والله احد الاصدقاء في طهران امس بعث لي
فيديو حب سجن ايفين الاف مؤلفه من الناس
همم اولادهم اعتقلوا وهم لا يعلموا احياء
اموات وقفوا امام سجن لان هذه الاحتجاجات
تفوق كثير وزخمها لازال والدليل
الاستمواعها الى هذا اليوم واليوم الجواد
تتكلم انه حتى بعض المسؤولين وتصور انه
يعني مثل عبد الكريم الذي هو المفكر اليوم
يتكلم عن النظام يقول النظام يعتقد انه
20%
هم المحتجين و20% هم المؤيدين بالنظام 60%
يقول هؤلاء ومادين يعتقد انهم هم ليسوا مع
السياسه يقول وانا اقول ان ال 60 % من
الاكثويه الصامته طيب فترونهم يتحولون مع
المتظاهرين فماذا سوف تعملون كتب اليوم
همم رجائي غلام علي رجائي في سته وي صبح
قال انه في اي دوله من العالم لو يحدث هذه
القتلى الاستقاله ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
لندن الكاتب المختص في الشان الايراني
دكتور نبيل الحيدري لك دكتور نبيل على هذه
المشاركه
اعلن رئيس مجلس نظرات البجا ان البيانا
الانفصالي للجنه السياسيه لا يمثلوا شرق
السودان الامانه السياسيه لمجلس نظارات
البيجا في شرق السودان كانت قد اعلنت عدم
اعترافها بحكومه الخرطوم وان المجلس هو
وحده السلطه السياديه لشعب الاقليمي واشار
بيان للكيان السياسيه الذي يضم قبائل
البيجا الى ان الهيئه العليا للمجلس هي
البرلمان والتشريعي العرفي الاقليم كما
قامت بتشكيل لجنه السياديه لتقرير المصير
على ان تقوم بعمل الحكومه المؤقته داعيه
الى تصعيد ثوري شامل في الخامس عشر من
نوفمبر الجاري
اعلن رئيس الفرنسيه
لمكافحه الارهاب في الساحل الافريقي رسميا
وقلم مكروه اثناء عرض استراتيجيه الدفاع
الفرنسيه
استهدفت وجودها العسكريه في افريقيا
اكبر في المستقبل ولا يجب الخضوع لها
واشار الى ضروره حمايه حلف الناتو وتعذيذه
وليس الى اضعافه
النوويه الفرنسيه ستساهم في سلامه اوروبا
التي باتت عرضه لضربات من طائرات بدون
طيار والصواريخ
نشاطنا مستمره هو في ايضا
منظمه امريكيه غير حكوميه تطلق خدمه
البيانات للكشف عن التغيرات التي تحدث في
الغابه
اهلا بكم جديد قال المدير الاقليمي منطقه
الشرق الادنى والاوسط باللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر فابريزيوكربوني قال ان خطرا
انتشار الاصابه بالكوليرا والاسهال الحاد
في سوريا ولبنان يمثل عبئا جديدا يفاقم
معاناه الناس في هذين البلدين اللذين
يعانين حاليا بما فيه الكفايه مع التاكيد
ان هناك حاجه ماسه لايجاد حلول
لتعزيز قدره البنيه التحتيه الحيويه على
الصمود مشيرا ايضا الى ان هذه المجتمعات
هي التي تدفع ثمن انهاك انظمه الرعايه
الصحيه وانظمه المياه والصرف الصحي التي
باتت على شفاء الانهيار
نزاع الممتد لاكثر من 11 عاما في سوريا ما
يعني الحاقه ضرر بالغ بشبكات المياه مع
التردد اوضاع النظافه الصحيه العامه
وبالتالي سهوله الاصابه بعدوى الكوليرا
المنتشر كذلك في لبنان امدادات المياه في
سوريا جراء الحرب انخفضت بنسبه تتراوح بين
30 و 40 بالمئه بحسب اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر والاماكن ذات الكثافه
السكانيه العاليه كما رافقه الاحتجاج
ومخيمات النازحين واللاجئين هي اكثر عرضه
لتفش الامراض وتبيعاتها
الصليب الاحمر يسدد على ان الحيلوله دون
انهيار البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه هو ضروره
حتميه لتجنب بتبيعات صحيه وانسانيه مهلكه
ما عم بيروت المزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع ايمان الطرابلسي المتحدثه باسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في الشرق
الاوسط والادنى ستمان اهلا وسهلا بك الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه اولا هل خرج
الكوليرا فعليا سواء في لبنان او في سوريا
عن السيطره ام لا هذه المبالغات لا اساس
لها من الصحه لانه ما زال بالامكان
السيطره عليه بشكل تام
اييه
اليوم في سوريا ولبنان جديد
يعانون من اثار الازمات همم او النزاعات
همم السابقه هذا الانتشار ان ان ان اثر
بدول سياقات اخرى تعاني من اثر النزاعات
كالعراق واليمن همم اليوم همم انتشار
حالات الكوليرا في الى السياقين سوريا
ولبنان يعد ناقوس خطر لتحدي اكبر من مجرد
انتشار الامراض الماضيه الا وهو تحالق نظم
الخدمات الاساسيه والثمن كما اا
كما اشرتهم تدفعه
المجتمع حتى المحليه التي تعاني اليوم في
من السياقين من اثر انحاق انظمه الرعايه
الصحيه وانظمه المياه والصرف الصحي التي
بدات على على شفا انهيار
كانت اكثر من منظمه اكثر من مدير من منظمه
انسانيه سواء دوليه او اقليميه يعني حتى
يعني عندما يخرج للحديث معي في في البرامج
عبر العربيه يحذر منذ اكثر من 10 سنوات من
انهيار شبكات الصرف الصحي
ومياه الشفاء بفعل همم الحرب او ضغط
النزوح اللجوء ومع ذلك لم يتحرك احد لماذا
الاتفاق الان يعني طب ما هذا كان متوقع
اه اريد ان اشير بان بالفعل يعني المنظمه
الفاعلين الانسانين على اختلافهم ااا
كانوا يدقون ناقوس الخطر منذ منذ مده حول
الشيء حول حول خطر انهيار البنا التحتيه
في عده سياقات ليس فقط في سوريا ولبنان
لكن العديد من الثقات داخل المنطقه
العربيه المتاثره بالنزاعات اذ اليوم
نعتبر ان انتشار الامراض المعديه هو همم
يعني همم قمه جبل الجليد المشكل الاساسي
هو همم الخطر انهيار البنيه التحتيه التي
حدد هذه السياقات فالكوليرا همم خطر
انتشار او او انتشار حالات الكوليرا اليوم
تعتبر جزء من المشكله يعني همم ليست ليست
بشكل مباشر ما المطلوب الان بشكل عاجل
سواء من السلطات او المنظمات الدوليه وهل
هلا اللقاحات متوافره هل الادويه متوفره
ام لا يعني الامور حدث ولا حرج
بالطبع هناك حاجه لمزيد الاستجابه
للاحتياجات الامنيه والطريقه التي خلقت
منجره الانتشار هذا الانتشار في مختلف
السياقات ونحن همم من طرفنا نعمل على دعم
مرافق مياه وسلطه الصحيه بالشراكه مع
الشركائنا من همم كان الهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري والصليب الاحمر اللبناني
مواجهه عفوا هذا انتشار في كلاسيين همم
ولكن ناكد بانه بالاضافه الى هذه
اوليه هناك حاجه ماسه لمواصله الدعم على
المستوى البعيد لايجاد حلول اكثر استداما
تهدف الى تعزيز القدره قدره البنيه
التحتيه على الصمود تحدي الكبير اليوم هو
ان اا هذه الحلول البعيده الامل تحتاج الى
مستوى كبير من الدعم والمحدث هنا عن الدعم
الدولي ولكن ااه قدره الفاعلين الانسانيين
على المساهمه في هذه الاستجابه الانيه
وبعيده المدد محدده بخطر انخفاض تمويل
عمليات انسانيه التي اصبحت حاليا واقعاني
منه كل الفاعلين الانسانين في مختلف
السياقات اسباب معدده متعدده ولكن يشير
لان الحلول تتجاوز ما يمكن ان يقدمه
الفعاليم الانسانين حتى مع
تقدم او اا او تكثير الدعم على مستوى
الدولي لا يمكننا ان نلعب دول يتجاوز دور
المهام الموكله للفاعلين الانسانيه وتبقى
الحلول الاساسيه
بالاحمر في الشرق الاوسط والادنه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
قال رسول الله الكرديه ان عدد النساء
والاطفال الاجانب من تنظيم داعش الذين
استعدتهم دول من مخيمات الاحتجاج في شمال
شرق سوريا سجل رقما قياسيا هذا العام
[موسيقى]
اطلقت منظمه امريكيه غير حكوميه خدمه
بيانات عبر التكنولوجيا متطوره للكشف عن
التغيرات التي تحدث في الغابات مثل تراجع
مساحتها والحرائق التي تنشب فيها لاسيما
وان ثلثها تقع خارج المناطق الغابات
الرسميه
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه وفينكم
بها التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]